so you went to Turks and Caicos tell me
that you flew first class yeah yeah I
balled out on points I had I hadn't
spent any of my credit card points ever
since I've gotten this [__] car the
chase one like literally it's been 15
years get the [__] out of here yeah you
must have so many [__] points I had a
million points
which is which is the equivalent of ten
thousand dollars yes so it's not that
like a million points sounds like a [__]
ton but like it's their value in years
of spending on this card yeah
I I would think would equate to more
points than that but whatever I'm not
complaining it's [__] great I mean we
you know I I was able to you know comp
the flight basically did you transfer
them to a different Airline or did you
go straight through the like Chase
travel portal
wait why because that's where they they
value them the lowest that way what yeah
they're valued at a penny
and if you transfer them they could be
valued as high as three cents I could
get trip I could well it depends what
airline did you fly JetBlue
yeah yeah I don't know I think that's
one point two five oh for the love
let's ruin it it's okay dude it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
I will never I'm just gonna only think
back to this with sour memory
because I knew I couldn't yeah I just
know I could have gone more you know no
it was JetBlue is great the JetBlue mint
is [__] fantastic oh yeah it's
awesome yeah absolutely amazing but on
the way there
so the the red eye to Miami is I mean
we're talking flight Logistics right now
I know you like to talk about that yeah
yeah okay yeah baby yeah oh yeah baby
let's get into it so you did a red-eyed
in Miami yeah I don't know if anyone
else likes to listen to this stuff who
cares [__] them fast forward if you
don't like it [__] no it also interests
me yes I do like booking flights because
I like to look up the plane and look up
the the interior figure out they got the
lay flat seats yeah all that [__] so
yeah I did that booked so okay so I'm
just gonna do a little Logistics here
I'm I'm intrigued no I thought it was
just gonna be yeah we got a red eye
there's only a few flights to Turks and
Caicos a day right because it's a really
small airport there's like three
American flights and and some flights on
I think there's a jet blue one there's
like one Delta one Whatever right so
getting business for that flight was
like three times the amount as the
cross-country flight with delay flat
seats so instead of doing that I just I
booked on separate Airlines so I booked
JetBlue from LA to Miami so we could
have like a nice business class lay flat
and it was a red eye so we could sleep
and then I just booked coach from there
to because it's like an hour and a half
flight oh but that means you have Turks
and Caicos is in the Caribbean right
yeah yeah yeah but that means you have
to get you have to like get your bags
and then go back through you have to
recheck and go back through security
yeah
and they lost Kelsey's bag the first air
the first flight did JetBlue lost it and
they're like oh we'll just you know
we'll put it on your next flight and
we're like well we're on a separate
Airline and they're like oh
well we'll just give it to the airline
and you just have to have to hope that
they're gonna send it and it's got to go
through customs and everything right
it's like an unintended bag going
through customs
and the way we got it was someone at the
resort had a friend that worked at the
Turks and Caicos airport like once it
was in the hands of American
they didn't hit us up they didn't tell
us that the bag was on its way nothing
we just like hoped that they put it on
the plane yeah and then an air tag in it
or anything no nothing
and it's our honeymoon right it's day
one I'm like I got all my bags I'm
chilling so so sorry I'm in my I'm in my
swim trunks I'm in the ocean like babe
you gotta get in here it's amazing she's
in a full sweatsuit because it's the
only thing she has but I bet she was a
champ about it she was a champ she was a
[__] Champ
it's it's a really it's a really
annoying thing to happen especially on a
honeymoon especially when you're in a
tropical destination and you have
nothing but a [__] sweatsuit but she
was a champ honestly she she had a great
day anyways and for dinner she wore my
clothes
and uh it was just a funny you know and
then the next day like I said like one
of the ladies that works at the hotel
was just super nice and she was like I
have a friend who works at the airport
I'll hit him up so she hit him up and he
just went back there and just was able
to find the bag and put it on a car and
they drove to the hotel wow so it all
but if she didn't know someone there we
wouldn't have been like that bag would
have just stayed there forever yeah oh
man so it all worked out but yeah that
that's uh that's the flight story cool
have your phone mint I have flown mint I
let's see what have I flown I've flown
American First in business I've flown
JetBlue mint I've flown Singapore
Airlines first class and
let's see what was the other one uh
Emirates first class oh what was the
best one Emirates Emirates was by far
the best really holy [__] jelly yes
what do they do like it's just the the
everything all the food is on demand and
it's just top shelf everything and uh
yeah you get to take a shower and um be
naked you get naked yeah oh yeah right
you get to be naked on an airplane which
is a wild that is pretty cool I do that
often but you're not supposed to yeah no
you're really not
they frown upon that sort of thing it's
business class what I can't get naked
yes I thought it was mind your own
business but
but uh yeah it's uh oh God it [__]
rocks it it reminds me of when you get
like really good seats at a at a sport
game like basketball or baseball and you
just go God I could just I gotta I gotta
say [__] everything I gotta Goggins mode
and just and just become like a [__]
billionaire yeah just just trample over
everybody and [__] sell my soul to
the devil because these seats Rock right
right right and eating caviar rocks oh
there's David Goggins
[Laughter]
for inspiration he completed 4030
pull-ups in 17 hours and 45 minutes
Jesus Christ
well so the the whole [__] actually
never mind this is unrelated but um keep
going about the flight that's it that's
it you're performing private
um no because I care about the
environment
yeah I I care yeah neither my carbon
footprint uh yeah yeah why have you no
no you know there's a company now I have
by the way and I'll tell you I'll tell
you when after but there's a company now
where you can pay them
to cancel your flight like the carbon
emissions of your flight they'll suck
the carbon out of the environment out of
the it's real it's [__] real carbon
capture is a real thing now and they
capture the amount of carbon that you
just emitted into the air via your
flight you can pay to have them suck
that back out what do they do with it
they put it in the soil I don't know
why don't they just do it all the time I
think it's the scale like you know you
can't like reverse global warming yet
but like this there's a lot of potential
in this technology to reverse global war
well and it probably offset it probably
puts a lot of carbon out there to power
the machine
but you can pay another company to suck
that carbon yeah that's right that's
right it's it's one big Ponzi scheme of
of all these [__] scenes man yeah so
why don't we have this so every time I
fly private I make sure to suck the
carbon out to pay this company yes
because I care about the environment
yeah the only times I've flown private
was with post Malone
and it was that's the only times I've
done it so you know didn't have to pay
for it right
um but it is that's truly just another
level I wouldn't like that because I
like this I like to be around the other
people because that by comparison it
makes you feel even better
seeing the people walk past you and
you're like I'm already sitting down I
got my [__] water and they're serving
me champagne and the constant service
like do you get service on a private
plane yeah yeah there's like a flight
attendant okay is the food good
yeah it was good okay I think from what
I'd remember we did it one time we did
it one time I've done it twice one time
it was from LA to Vegas so like this
like a 30 minute flight yeah it's
nothing and then the other time was in
um was in uh [__]
uh Santa pay I think from we flew from
Paris to Santa pay whoa and that one I
think it was like part of like a sort of
like a luxury like vacation package so I
think they did do yeah food on that one
but that that was an unbelievable
experience truly damn
it's it's just crazy because you don't
like there's no like security or
anything you know there's no lines
there's nothing you know yeah I did a
one of those uh blade
flight things from um in New York from
their little Hub to JFK and it's like a
three minute flight
and uh it's because I got like half off
so I was like you know it's it's a
hundred bucks that'd be the same price
as an Uber yeah and it was in three
minutes it was it was easy and I got to
like land in the airport and then a GMC
Yukon was there to pick me up and it
took me straight to the security
man it rocks
so anyway this episode's all about how
we're better than you and no about how
we're losing touch oh yeah losing touch
oh for sure yes well I haven't changed
my socks in a week so I don't know if
that um that that brings me down you
told me you showered the morning but you
did then you put on dirt you put re-put
on dirty socks well okay so these are
smart wool socks and they oh they Wick
sweat and I haven't really been doing
anything that active except for like
hitting the gas and the brake in my car
um in my [__] rental car because my
car got stolen and oh yeah what because
you left the keys in it no no I didn't
do that